yeah hello and welcome to insight
Germany
my guest today is an entrepreneur who
was born in India educated in the United
States and took a business degree at
Harvard University a year and a half ago
he moved to Berlin and set up a brand
new business
Noreen Shaam is the boss of an
innovative travel company called go euro
welcome to the show paraben I should say
the first the full title of your company
which is go euro dot-com because it's an
internet travel company now there's
loads of them out there so what's unique
about yours yes first of all we have no
euro dot d e dot you code or UK door yes
not I T dot F R oh I see you know all
the European different exactly exactly
your comm would work it's all the same
it works the website is the same yeah
fundamentally what we do is is different
than any other travel website out there
the major differences we bring all modes
of travel into one one website so it's
basically one search for you to find out
what's the most efficient way to get
from one place to the other and so so
just to get in in the detail you're
going from Edinburgh to London or from
Berlin to Frankfurt or Berlin to Prague
for example you type in Berlin fraud we
will tell you that flight is I guess
four hours it takes an hour to the
airport an hour check-in an hour flight
and an hour on the other side so we
never show one-hour flight as a one-hour
flight it's the total journey time and
the cost to get there and we compare
that to the Train also probably four
hours and and and the price and then a
bus is probably six hours and the price
and based on your price elasticity you
select which mode of travel
so basically we're bringing all the
options into one website so you don't
have to search for websites to figure
out whether of buses faster or cheaper
than a train but what is the difference
in the time versus price that I'm
willing to pay
in this is India in basic what we do but
beyond this we allow search more natural
travel search like I don't know Expedia
kayak orbits or all the big ones they
fundamentally have been focused on air
transportation and which is you go from
airport to airport London Heathrow to
EDI is Edinboro we do more natural
search I'm going from like said
Edinburgh and I want to go to Cambridge
in the UK I want to type Cambridge and
let go euro find out what's the best
airport to fly to and also the train to
the airport so it's not just comparing
but we also combine to give complete
journeys and it's not because there's I
mean Germany has 25 airports but 9,000
train stations how do I get the other
we're gonna hear more about that in the
report coming up and must be difficult
but what gave you the idea to do this
yeah I traveled Europe for about four
months in 2010 I did I think 14
countries
I was just backpacking and I realized
that ground transportation in Europe is
phenomenal it's really I of all over the
world I think train the optionality of
trains and buses the convenience of
getting to the city centre is really
it's it's very well laid out
infrastructure but then the ability to
find all these options in one place is
is is very dispersed like and I don't
know most people you could have I mean
you came from America yeah you could run
it in America much more easily you could
made more money with longer distances no
I don't think so cuz in general the u.s.
it doesn't apply people who fly the
geography is very different than Europe
people mostly fly or take a bus the
there's no comparison of of the two but
in Europe it's so close to each other
that the the need for people to switch
more big based on total travel time and
price is much more in Europe and that's
why I even called it go Europe because
it's very Europe centric and it's not
easily applicable to the rest of the
globe yeah it's harder maybe to get
around Europe in such a way it is
especially I mean in general it is easy
to get around but it's hard to find how
to get around
sorry that's German yeah how did you get
the finance okay that's that's one of
the harder questions in general it's
never easy to raise money it really is
not in other you're in Silicon Valley or
in New York it's it's just never easy
especially if it doesn't matter which
whether you went to Harvard or whether
you're it's just hard to raise money
what I mean
in general it I guess what we're
building is is a very big opportunity in
a new space of travel it hasn't been
done before and the opportunity it's
really big
and when you find investors who go after
a big vision and if you show early
traction then that's a good mix of you
know it's slowly early traction what
does that mean so I guess let me
it depends what company you built if
you're building if you're building
something that's more social like social
media then you need to have traction to
bring in finances what we build is is
contractual I mean for me to launch in
Germany I need to have Deutsche Bahn and
and all the big bus companies like euro
lines they see the city my fan base all
the names exactly so for me in it be
ability to demonstrate that we can do
this is by going and getting contracts
and then when you go and gather to the
investors and say now we have all the
contracts now let me raise money and
build out this this proof of concept and
that's kind of what we did in the last
round it was a huge around it was and
then how much the finance is German
Finance uh half is German and is that
very I mean the other half is American /
yes Honorine and what are the different
conditions of American Finance and
German Finance and the Germans much
tougher in what they have yeah I think
so I don't know no no no in general
raising money in Germany is tougher it's
much tougher because people are
investors everything are risk less risky
most investors I want to say haven't
seen 10 companies go through the full
lifecycle so most of them probably I
how many of them even know what it takes
to raise ten rounds of finances or five
until you sell it's not just I raise
finances until I get to the next round
and then I figure out what to do it's
basically future thinking on what
happens through the different lifecycle
of the company this experience is is
limited so in general terms are tougher
in Germany but birth Wow I mean oh yeah
yeah I have to I have to do that I am in
Germany we're building a company in
Europe I have to go to European
investors because I need to execute your
I need to hire labor here I need to I
need to get access to new contracts I
need to build a market here and I mean
that is possible because people on the
ground here know how to do this so it's
not I can't get around the fact that I'm
gonna get American money and build it
it's impossible okay we've talked enough
about the whys and wherefores let's have
a look at how it all works
Marie Nowakowski is planning a weekend
trip from Heidelberg to London she
browses the internet for the cheapest
and fastest route there's plenty of
choice but it's difficult to get an
overview you could go by plane car or
train but there are separate sites for
each mode of transport when I'm planning
a trip I use the national rail website
or Expedia and shop around just planning
and searching the web already takes up
to three or four hours and that's just
too much the go euro website aims to
fill a gap in the market for a trip from
Heidelberg to London it draws up
itineraries with optimized combinations
of different means of transport the trip
might kick off with a train ride to the
next Airport in London a shuttle bus
continues into the city centre all
booked in one go go euro is a Berlin
based startup which is still in the test
phase database specialists are currently
working to get as many transport
providers on board as possible
founder NAR and shams set out on this
mission two years ago
bringing this data together is a crazy
idea but it's I don't think it's
unreasonable if it solves a problem and
people are facing this problem every day
somebody has to solve it the project has
received three million euros of funding
by various investors there are
competitors way meit is just one of them
but all of them face the same uphill
battle getting to the stage where they
can have full coverage of all European
cities data records for a myriad of bus
and rail companies are often difficult
to access Andreas Klee is the head of
the innovation center for mobility and
societal change in Berlin the transport
expert is familiar with the fragmented
European market it's difficult because
the transport industry isn't ready yet
they all still live in their own world
bus companies think in terms of buses
rail companies in terms of trains car
rentals in terms of rented cars they
don't link up the public transport in
Europe is still living in the 19th
century
rome wasn't built in a day right so we
will have to go country by country and
integrate trains buses everything and
then we launched one country and then we
moved to the next country Marino
Bukowski's visit to the website was
definitely worth it it only took her a
few clicks to book her trip to London
now she has plenty of time to pack and
my guest is now Ren Shan do you have
nerves of steel
I built them over the last year yeah I
would say sure ok you said that rome
wasn't built in a day
how long is it gonna take you a year
probably at least to get most of Western
Europe really yeah so we are moving very
fast we're growing very fast my problem
now is that I don't have enough
resources reintegrate the number of
contracts we have in the pipeline it's a
good problem to have
but we are moving much faster but it's
also like I said rome wasn't built in a
day we can't have every country in all
over Europe every tiny town village
searchable on day one it just is
impossible
I mean this bus train flight business
getting it all together that's obviously
why you're traveling you mentioned to me
you've traveled 12 countries in the last
three weeks the expert there in that
report said that it's still in the
nineteenth century didn't even say the
20th century with the 19th century the
world buses and trains but so but is it
really that archaic the whole system
it is close to historical in general and
the easiest way to explain it is is just
if you look at the air industry txl as
Berlin Tegel lhr as London Heathrow so
whether you search in Boone Osiris or
your Sydney it's always you type in lhr
it's always London Heathrow because
systems underlying databases are all
standardized in what's called GDS as
global distribution systems but when you
come to the train and bus space every
company has its own internal databases
so they don't talk to each other there's
no way in London st. Pancras or Paris
Gare du Nord is exact same station is a
different station code in deutsche bahn
then talis then SNCF then in your store
yeah I can see it's complicated let's
leave it at that
now you did send us some pictures yeah
strangely enough this first picture is
of you as an airport I think yeah yeah
yeah and who's that that's that's me and
my brother actually I think this is
probably New York Airport JFK when we
were dropping my mom off at the airport
I think so
I see you weren't actually doing
business in this photo
no well that's nice to know yeah yeah
and wait well we'll have another one
where I think I don't think you're doing
business here either no this was one of
my best friends Ernesto from Harvard he
got married in in Rio in Brazil and this
was me trying to be the I guess I guess
he's just imitating the Statue exactly
now five five people working for go euro
in March yep I think this 32 now 30 to
35 we're 32 or something like that I
lost come now is it mostly Germans or is
it very multi card is very multi
go through something I'm extremely proud
of and I actually share with anybody who
comes in the office or investors is
we're from 12 nationalities and we're
50% women so it's very it's very diverse
it's it's really multicultural the main
reason is that it's not it's not it's
it's out of need when we go to Spain or
when we go to the UK we need English
people to code and program and know the
geography on how train and buses work
and then same for marketing I have to
quickly say that I went to England about
two weeks ago and I went I came back
then I went recent researching for this
interview I went on your website night
I'd rather rather Santa say well that
you could have got me there cheaper so
congratulations to you why Berlin lots
of hype about a Silicon Valley in Berlin
yeah but is it all hype or is there
really business going on here no there's
definitely really business it's not it's
it's far from Silicon Valley it's it's
not there's no I mean it's not it's
Berlin is Berlin it's not Silicon Valley
it will never be but it's not hype it's
there's a lot of business going on
there's a lot of good companies being
formed here the ecosystem is being built
slowly it's still at its nascent stages
in general for the ecosystem you need
good entrepreneurs and people who work
who take a risk to work for a start-up
instead of taking a job at Daimler or
Bosch or or Siemens one of the big
companies that I want to work for a
young innovative company there's this
need from people is definitely there in
Berlin access to finances it's still
very slow so this needs to catch up and
then a few exits have to happen because
when exits happen all the people who
sold now will reinvest back into the
ecosystem because that is their world
that's all we live in this is all I've
been doing for so many years and I want
to do it again so that part hasn't
happened so there is a long way but it's
definitely not hype I believe in the
ecosystem here I am very happy to be
part of the early stages of the
ecosystem where it's still not you know
as well established as New York or even
Tel Aviv or San Francisco for example
but it will get there I'm very positive
and
I hope I'm part of this but when you
came to Germany there were various
problems like opening a bank account
yeah you know and and being allowed to
work here yeah how do you I mean how did
you overcome these things uh yeah I was
very lucky I had a host family my
friend's parents basically adopted me in
in their house and they helped me a lot
there's a lot of loopholes in order to
get our bank account you need a legal
address in order to get a legal address
you need a I forget loopholes right now
but in order to get a legal address you
need a rent contract in order to get a
rent contract you need a bank a tour so
you can break this loophole easily so
what I had my host family who took me
and give their address you see you had
to have an address that's very German
yeah yeah okay did it did it did it at
all sort of worry you you'd you'd put
all your eggs in one basket and come to
a country where you didn't speak the
language and with all these minor well
not minor but from the business point of
view
I can't open a bank account I can't you
know get registered didn't you sit begin
to think oh my goodness I should have
gone to London or I don't know where
y'all stayed in New York opening a bank
account is my worst of my worries I
would never be an entrepreneur
yeah there's tougher problems that come
in life these are just I want to say
nuisances that you overcome very quickly
yeah but generally you would think of
Germany being a good place to have a
business on the heart you know I mean
it's they could I mean they could make
it easier to open a business here the
the legal system and everything it's
harder to hire talent for example from
outside cause the visa process is not
very clear so there's definitely your
roadblocks that can be removed but I
won't say it's a bad place to do
business I mean there's a lot of good
entrepreneurs who come not from Germany
and start businesses here but but maybe
these roadblocks are also to make it a
safer safer for your business so it
depends I mean if if I give you an
example if we get a lot of international
people from we have people from New
Zealand from Brazil from
from Belorussia exedra and when they
apply for the visa we don't know how
long it takes it may be anything from
two weeks to three months and as a
start-up you're running on a tight cash
schedule so you can't predict so I don't
know if it makes any safer or unsafe of
course you know you need you can't have
no regulation at all where you know you
can do what it's not very flow yeah some
restrictions but of course it can be
easier like I don't know enough about
the tax system here but I heard Germans
complain about the tax system as well
can it be easier sure I think so well
all I can say to that and I'll be
careful what I say is at least we pay
our taxes you came to Berlin for
commercial reasons not because it's
cooked I mean you're a young guy you
didn't come here because it's cool
because of the great clubs like the
majority of young people or come here to
study you know so so apart from the
business advantages of Berlin I know you
fly around tremendous amount yeah but
are there other pluses to here what what
oh yeah there's a lot I love ala Germany
for many many reasons
in the autobahn I want to start with the
great road system I mean the
infrastructure he is very dependable I
know I can take a train and it's almost
always on time
as social security is very good here
safety I mean most I guess I want to say
most Germans don't realize how safe this
country is you go live in a country like
India India's also safe but there's so
many parts of the world that are still
you know I can't go out after 12 p.m.
alone or at 12 in the night alone or I
can't come back home alone I have to
take a taxi or I have to always travel
with a friend just because it's it's
unsafe so these are these things are
almost a given free education system I
mean in the u.s. it's still expensive to
go to school I have to take a lot of
borrow a lot of money to go to school so
Germany provides a lot of good things
for its people and I really respect this
this well-functioning economy here that
that I just have to come and fit in and
then everything functions around around
itself we've already discovered that my
guest spends a lot of
time living out of a suitcase but we
managed to catch up with him when rather
surprisingly he did have a bit of
downtime here in Berlin okay i Skype
with my parents once every week at least
once a week if I can come ah Monday San
Francisco the Wednesday Boston fly them
back it was nice when I am a little bit
more relaxed and stress-free and then I
try to them for easily an hour and now
I'm in Berlin I travel I don't know the
next three weeks seven seven countries
the last few weeks I wasn't I was on the
grain most of my time
and for me I want to come back home to
Berlin this is my home now my work is my
home now my work is my wife yeah I guess
I'm married to my job for the moment you
get once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
some build something big and you are
going through that right now just
I have a very I want to say stressful
life but I have a very full life very
packed in the morning I check my
calendars to see how much breathing the
room I have during the day and it's
normally maybe 12 to 12:30 and sometimes
it's good to just relax with my host
family okay that's where we started at
Alexanderplatz and now we're going to
mild stuff house family and I'll take
you guys there
when I moved to Germany one of the most
important things was my host family they
really helped me look everything was
different
everything was difficult but it's good
to have some amount of comfort and
people you trust that evening we were
invited to my boss mark and with my host
family they're all educated economists
so this is great for me cause I love
economics butas cooking is great because
one it's I think the first month I moved
she tried a lot of things when I eat the
whole plate that means she knows I loved
it when I give a little she knows that I
didn't really like it all my stuff is
still here I think okay just like my
other mom my German mom I think very
soon hopefully my real mom will be Odin
and I know it there they really think
the same I see my lovely family
yeah what do you think of the food here
now I mean I like some things of the
food case especially is my favorite
comfortable salad as well I think you
put that in our questionnaire I
immediately thought Kaiser space is
quite bland
yeah now this I'm sure you get a tell me
this a cliche but an Indian liking sort
of bland bland well I lived in the u.s.
I lived in the u.s. twelve years I see
yeah but no III like variety of food as
well I never eat the same thing two two
meals same cuisine for example and also
because I'm lucky that I travel so much
you know it's a Spanish or French or
Italian or or made Middle Eastern food I
just really like variety of food and I
can't eat a lot of meat so because of
that I'm limited in my choice and I try
to make the best of it
okay now your Harvard graduates a
high-flying businessman if I may say so
but instead of staying in a posh hotel
when you came here yeah you found a
family to stay out and excuse me saying
out in the sticks it's not in the center
of town yeah why did you do that I know
you had to have an address but I mean
why didn't you stay in a hotel and get
going I mean it's it's not it's not
personal I mean the whole point of I
mean what we do and I believe this so
strongly is Europe has such diversity in
culture and people and everything and if
I don't experience that from living in
the home of somebody I am NOT living in
Europe I'm living in a hotel like
tourism so I it for me it was completely
necessary to be if I'm gonna live here
which I when I moved from New York I had
made up my mind that I'm gonna live here
and for in order to do that I might as
well dive into it fully then stay in a
hotel find an apartment etc and is that
that is that as Martine yet that's
Martin there some contact in New York
exactly he was studying there he what he
was he was doing is there an exchange
semester and he he was actually in
Boston and he was to come to New York
cause he loves New York and he crashed
on my couch every time he was Aaron and
and is he involved in the business no
he's not he actually works in Frankfurt
all right okay oh we've got some more
pictures because I want to talk you
would not talk about your second okay we
want to talk about your family okay and
I want to see yeah this is so cute I for
the first time I've just waited one and
a half years staring cricket into the
conversation on inside Germany which has
nothing to do with Jerry but I mean
India's big huge cricket neisha and you
I am not such a big fan of cricket I
play basketball I used to play cricket
as a kid until I broke my nose because
of a stupid reason and since then I
stopped playing cricket and I just
picked up basketball well that's the end
of our cricket conversation here on
inside Germany which is just as well one
more
Jeff from your youth though there's a
rather light and I wondered that's there
we go that's you with your brother
that's me and my brother here and I
wondered those uniform so that is that
from a layover from British type tiles
yeah I think so I went to a I went to a
very Christian school called st. Paul's
and I mean what's missing here is the
blazer every day in the hot Sun we had
to wear a full blazer and a tie and it's
just burning inside but you used
compulsory and it's extremely strict so
and I had to buy cycle five kilometres
to school so yes it was it was the
uniform everything amazing amazing now
you're born in Bangalore which is the
third biggest city in India it's I
believe it's right isn't it right in the
middle of India it's so in the middle of
the southern part and is now known as
the Silicon Valley of India yeah I say
this is one of the top ten preferred
destinations for entrepreneurs in the
world you're not there at the moment
those okay but can you imagine going
back and doing business that yeah sure
if I have a good idea that can be built
into a billion dollar business from
Bangalore oh sure I would it be very
different doing business you would be
very different but again you have to
remember I'm I would be a second time
entrepreneur successful or not I still
have all the learnings and I'm happy for
what I'm doing now and all my lessons go
everywhere with me so I know what it
takes to bring things off the ground and
get it running growing up in India did
you I know anything about Germany ah not
really not really I just world war truth
the only thing we study and that's
probably the extent of my first exposure
to Germany was when I moved to the US
and then I started and then my travels
here and I was in Berlin in 2010
absolutely fell in love with the city
and that's why I decided there is not
just a good ecosystem for startups it's
also a good city to live in um what was
it that made you fall in love with that
I have to say Berlin has a very good mix
of alternative culture which is young
artistic
a lord of good energy but more so it's
very down-to-earth there's no there's no
fake aura that I need to have a lot of
money to have a successful life here
it's really down to earth and I really
like this because I come from a very
like it's middle-class family in India
and for me it's it's very easy to
connect with people that are down to
earth as well and this this I like about
Berlin a lot but some cities you really
need a lot of cash to and you have a has
a very good lifestyle and you don't hear
no I yeah there is a very much the truth
in that but it is very down-to-earth
yeah
you were in America yeah we should show
a very proud picture yeah I think yeah
was that offered yes there was harwaryee
was one of my best days and and what
what did you what was your award what
was your graduation you've got a I got a
I got a Masters in Business
Administration from Harvey M the NBA
Amos am I really
yeah yeah and we and just one more that
I saw I think now these are these are
Harvard friends yeah these are a couple
of my best friends from there Morgan is
actually French he's also an
entrepreneur and he works to New York
and her nest early I already mentioned
him he's Italian and he's uh he got
married in Rio he's married to a
Brazilian go and none of these guys over
the years are involved in your business
no but they have their own stuff yes
just wondering so you really had this
idea yeah you came on your own yeah a
lot of guts to come you just flew over
you obviously had a contact when you
landed they packed my bags and I was
here and then then what did you do next
after getting your bank account no yeah
I mean I was just in the beginning I was
I was really involved in my business I
started to do a few events and I
realized it wasn't much value so I we
have a no event policy in the company
now yeah you just get things moving
there's no secret sauce at all really
for me for our business it was to get
the contracts up and running to hire
people which was probably the toughest
challenge probably even more than
getting the contracts is I had to
convince Germans that hey I'm an
entrepreneur I'm going to bring in the
contracts and
gonna bring in the finances but work for
me for almost no cost because you need
to believe in my vision
so the initial stages are very difficult
to convince people I mean do they get
shares yeah most everybody after a
certain time getting shares in the
company yeah three months like yeah and
and did you put much of your own money
in it yes they put some of my own money
because yeah I mean we've skipped
through that but you had a successful
time in the car industry in in in
America didn't you yes I did i I grew up
the ranks very quickly in the car
industry I was a product manager and
then I moved on from there to Harvard
and then I went and worked in in in the
financial services industry in New York
so I had some let's say savings yeah
yeah I did put some money in to get it
up and running and is that where your
interest in fast cars and fast also
about start probably true I always loved
fast cars when I grew up in India I used
to I used to regularly watch Formula One
as a kid so fast cars is something I
really yeah I love and yeah it's not
just cars fast anything it slow slow
life is just not me I'm always on there
I can see that yeah Germany's a good
place for fast cars absolutely the best
I think yeah yeah well it's good car
manufacturers and the roads traffic
system let's let's support this yeah
it's not actually true that there's no
speed limit on the German Autobahn only
on certain stretches but even so from
around the world people head here to
tear up the rubber and even on the
country roads
just before we go on if you want to
write to us about speed limits in
Germany or any subject that comes up in
the show the address is in sites
DW de we always like to get post who
doesn't so drop us at hein
my guest is now in sharm who who likes a
bit of speed so do you own a Porsche yet
no I actually haven't had a car in a
very long time I used public
transportation to get there I have a
bicycle that I don't know where it is so
would you like to drive fast down the
motorway I would yeah yeah if I have an
opportunity to rent a car and drive I
have done it a few times as well
absolutely
I should mention once again that you can
drive a fast on German motorways but
it's not limitless there are one or two
places on the German Autobahn where it
is limitless but they are few and far
between but you can drive quite fast
yeah you left a well-paid job basically
to set up this business why why were you
so convinced yeah that's basically the
opportunity is is unique nobody has done
it before this bringing Europe in terms
of travel so the market is huge I think
last I checked on research reports 320
something billion euro market this is a
huge market and the the need from a
consumer point of view like if you're a
consumer I saw people searching on four
different websites trying to piece this
together that I was completely convinced
but it's also not just the idea was
whether I was happy in my previous job
or does it that I want to do I'm in
general much more risk er I guess my
lawyers company lawyers still I would
I'm one of the riskiest entrepreneurs
she's ever met even in even in among
entrepreneurs so yeah I mean it wasn't
something that I'm building something
that's useful for people versus just
working on deals so it's because it
seems to me it's not about the money
it's the noise it's the chase it's that
sort of thing to create something yeah
so when you've when you've run the race
yeah and got there will you leave it and
go on
the next one no I'll start the chase
again bit like a second wife you
mentioned you're married to your job
yeah yeah you know yeah yeah I mean oh
yes to answer yes I would absolutely do
that I mean the energy the ups and downs
here I guess I'm addicted to it after
this whatever happens yes or no I have
now a very good network of investors and
people so I will start over again and
build the next thing yeah I just don't
know yet what it is okay now you also
involved in something here in Berlin
called a startup bootcamp is that for
other on preneur entrepreneur yes III
have to say I'm I'm involved as best as
my time permits it's basically to help
others build up the ecosystem sharing my
knowledge how to raise money most of the
time I just make connections to them to
raise money
other times I tell them how to set up
the founders stock how to divide equity
between two or three founders to make it
fair and how to give shares to employees
what is fair in the market and how to
motivate them intrinsically rather than
you know just based on salary because
salary is something we can't match to
the Daimler's and and and and the and
the bosses so what is how to build a
company ground up how to how to get the
different elements lined up so that you
can get traction yeah I help out
and one other thing a different thing
you're involved in completely different
thing and I know you actually it's
something you don't talk about but you
give some of your money back don't you
you're paying for education of a number
of children yeah back in Bangalore yeah
yeah yeah that's something I actually
started doing 10 years ago after my
first job like I said I come from a very
middle-class family in India and to go
all the way up to Harvard is I have to
say is something I'm extremely proud of
and that comes because of education my
ability to now quit a well-paid job in
New York and do something that I really
want to do with this flexibility is
because I'm confident that if this
doesn't work I can easily find something
else that's because of education so I
think to change the entire country
towards the positive only happens
because of higher education
it's not a lot like I said it's a share
of my my my money but I've been doing it
regularly ten years every single month
and there are kids in Bangalore getting
an education yeah exactly
right now I think it's eight to ten and
my mom is is the other half of me that
makes sure that we get it we do not just
education we we buy books for them we
pay for your school fees sometimes we
also pay for health I think there's one
kid who had an illness so we paid for
medical stuff but by and large I focused
more of my personal efforts on education
because this is something I'm completely
convinced can change for the better
yeah I completely agree with you can't
change world and very good that you
wonderful that you do that sort of thing
finally we've nearly reached him we turn
to our questionnaire a couple of things
I want to ask you about the auto part
you said what are the things that you
say is a good German characteristic is
drivers cursing people from other
countries yeah I find it extremely
amusing when you sit next to a German
and they see the number played and they
will see it's from Frankfurt or
somewhere else they say oh this person's
from Frankfurt they don't know how to
drive or you know the other way around
or some other state in the country and
then they see a Dutch car or a Belgian
car all these villages they don't know
how to drive it's really amusing ferment
and irritating German characteristic
you've put down as no free water
investors yeah this really upsets me for
me it's like air is air is free and
water should be free I mean it's not
that there's no I see it's it's like my
birthright to get water but they they
are for you mineral water we should
cross out yeah exactly you have to pay
for it but more intense more upsetting
is the fact that when you ask for tap
water they don't like it they give you a
frustrated face then you're not you're
gonna save two euros on this bottle of
water so yeah but I know you love living
here really best kept secret in Germany
inside Germany they complain about
everything and outside they're proud of
everything Joan that's about the Germans
themselves you're saying
yeah especially any German if you if
you're traveling with them in New York
or anywhere in the US they say oh this
waterfall we have it in Germany all the
cars are not good enough like and here
are the train is late everything's not
working as it's supposed to research do
passionate about Germany outside but
inside yeah yeah it's very interesting I
think it's true of other perhaps others
as well yeah Noren sharm it's been
fascinating talking to you i know you've
got an app coming soon as well we hadn't
have time to talk about that good luck
with go euro thank you and look out for
that thank you very much for joining us
thank you for watching and join me next
time when there'll be another
fascinating guest on inside Germany
until then from me and all the crew here
in Berlin ba-bye